so you mentioned your Yuri epiphany came
when you were driving you know on the
road one Sunday right and you said you
were just I wasn't Sunday it was
November 14th 2005 so why were you so
miserable before and are you still
miserable or are you much you know
what's so funny I wasn't miserable at
all right I repositioned my family on
November 13th I thought it was the
happiest boy in art it just hit me it
was just like you know this is not what
I want to do anymore I want to do
something else and basically I walked in
and told one of my stock guys go to
Circuit City buy a camera it's like you
know it's just you know there's a lot of
things I believe in in life and one is
if you do what you love and you don't
lie to yourself you'll always win
regardless of what you're doing
I just don't lie to myself and that day
I was driving to work I'm like I'm 30
years old now do I like where I'm at am
i closer to buying the New York Jets no
all right I don't want to do this
anymore there's too much cool stuff
going on a million people just watched
Andy Samberg who came from the internet
do a skit on SNL wine has no hero or
somebody that's doing something
interesting and so I just you know I was
happy then I was I was only not happy
for about 28 minutes you know what I
mean it was just that drive that I just
knew that I had to do something
different and I did